le numéro un aujourd'hui quelle puce le
belon mathieu allée g permet d'abord à
préambule des cours maintenant c'est une
date qui tombe mal et je suis très
heureux ce soir parce que c'est la
première année où je fait de mal c'est
la saint valentin en couple donc ça me
met en couple quel couple qu'elle forme
[Musique]
est là vous en ferez ce que vous voulez
célibataire à cette date là et donc
c'est ça me fait bizarre je n'ai pas
besoin de réfléchir
oui ça me vire tout de suite le plus
gros boulard de l'équipe c'est jean luc
lemoine
non c'est vrai absolument absolument il
est c'est un garçon qui a beaucoup de
talent mais qui est assez susceptibles
on va il a conscience de son talent
qu'on voulait donc susciter ou bouddha
comprends pas bien français
[Rires]
car tu es sûr que c'est bon pour tes
cheveux sales
attention voilà mes frères vous avez
fait n'importe quoi car il vous fait une
chute sous cape foutait de ma gueule moi
non mais sans déconner mettre n'importe
quoi dans un truc c est les gars est
donc quelques caves à le boire
mais bien sûr le voir daniel non non non
pas par nous mais aussi bien sûr quand
on est très bas daniel tu vas boire sa
réelle
tu vas boire ça m'a daniel et on va voir
si elles tombent amoureux elle tombe
amoureuse quoi s'en tenir et qui
régressent spontanément
bonsoir le plus grand boulard de
l'équipe c'est mathieu alors le plus
gros boulard mois pour le connaître
depuis des années je peux c'est dans
cette voie que non mais effectivement
oui c'est mathieu
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais ouais
face aux aléas très chaude art
sur moi alors 20 secondes est bon il
reste chauffer ce qui va se passer ça
chauffe ça chauffe à l'intérieur
jean-michel mais comme je les aime
beaucoup mais mathieu je suis désolé
mais évidemment ça ne peut être que
mathieu est malheureusement grosse tête
et petit zizi ça mauvais coup 3
[Applaudissements]
et le prime à jean michel vous pouvez
pas venir après avec moi je vis en
artois
au fait j'ai envie de me rapprocher de
quelqu'un et puis sur la droite voila
voila c'est peut-être quand même cépage
et je pense je voyais est d'accord c'est
vraiment hormonal lucy punch bassin vous
surprendre mais la personne qui a le
plus le la grosse tête c'est valérie
benaïm je déconne c'est mathieu
[Musique]
moi j'ai des offres mais il est plus
lisse yeux parce que ils jouent aux mecs
qui a la grosse tête pour cacher le fait
qu'il a vraiment dit ça c'est vrai moi
tu veux vous donner vous donner mon avis
également marraine pour moi je dis et
franchement je demande aux agrumes
oui je le droit de mettre les rues celui
qui a la plus grosse tête celui qui l'a
le plus le boulard de toute l'équipe
franchement pour moi c'est mathieu et
moi je vais je n'hésite pas une seconde
et c'est comme ça que je vous aime ne
faisait pas eh oui on vous avec le barça
viendra si l'écho boulard et vous
méritez votre boulard voilà vive le
boulard capacités physiques pour faire
ans avec les stars mais si vous le
faisiez ce serait pas rebaptiser abah
abah je vous lis que george frey danse
avec les stars c'est que sur fond du
trou il avait hérité bah oui c'est la
vérité franchement c'est vrai s'arrêter
c'est une tannée ces quatre heures
d'entraînement par jour
les mecs qui travaillent les mecs qui
travaillaient mais pas le temps ou de
boulot ils sont pas dans ses coups de
coeur est ce qu'on veut ce qu'on fait ce
plh parce qu'ils aient mais plombé
[Rires]
mais
dijon n'aura pas bien ce soir écoute
j'adore plongée c'est ma passion des
chevaux un truc